hi there steve kaufman here
tomorrow friday we start the 90 day
challenge
doesn't matter what language you're
learning
you can participate
and
again tomorrow at 10 a.m pacific
standard time
we're going to have the first of my
language workouts and i'm going to talk
a little bit about both those things but
i wanted to remind you again the 90-day
challenge starts tomorrow friday
february 1.
and so do my
language workouts but first a little
story and so my wife and i like to golf
here in palm springs and typically we
show up as a twosome men were put
together with another couple yesterday
we were with a couple from ohio who were
also visiting palm springs
and of course after a few holes we
established what we used to do did do in
life he was a dentist
and of course i mentioned link website
for language learning that i'm doing
with my son
and so he said you know
how quickly can i become fluent in
italian
and i said well how motivated are you
and he said i'm motivated because my
wife is of italian origin and two years
from now we intend to i'm going to
retire he says my son is in my practice
and we're going to go to italy for a
month
so i said well you definitely can become
fluent uh within a two-year period in
fact you can achieve a lot in three
months you can achieve a major
breakthrough in three months you can
achieve so much that you will be
encouraged to stay with it you'll be
enjoying your language learning so much
that you'll stay with it until you
become fluent but it's that initial
period to get you going to where you
feel you're achieving you know progress
because so many people have told me that
at some level they wanted to become
fluent in spanish italian or something
uh but then they never quite get there
they buy a book or they go to class but
they never achieve any success so that's
where i think the 90-day challenge comes
in is we commit ourselves to working
just about every day
and
if we do that
we will certainly achieve a breakthrough
and i think even more than that i felt
with this uh dentist from ohio if i
could have him
you know at least three times a week you
know do the things that i do if people
will only do the things that i do and
and that maybe not everybody wants to do
that now not everybody wants to listen
to the same ministory 30 40 50 times but
if you do do that you will achieve
amazing success and after that then
you're off and running
so
90 day challenge is to get everyone to
focus on their language to make a
special effort to achieve that
breakthrough and
the language workouts i'm not you know
this is an absolutely brand new
experience for me
i'm gonna do it
sometimes on my computer
and sometimes i'm going to connect my
ipad
to my computer so that i can share this
on google hangouts youtube etc the
technology is new to me there could be
some glitches
you will have an opportunity to ask
questions as i'm doing it uh
i'm going to begin it with a bit of an
explanation in each case of what i'm
going to be doing in the half hour these
will be about a half hour long sessions
and then i'm just going to study as if i
were studying and
you know it'll depend on my mood what i
feel like doing and so three monday
wednesday and friday at least that's the
plan right now three times a week i'm
going to share
and at 10 o'clock in the morning pacific
standard time i'm going to share
my
study activities with you i'm working on
farsi and arabic so it'll either be
farsi or arabic that i'm working on each
time
but you can be doing whatever language
because the actual you know activities
the principles of what we do are the
same
so i look forward to having you
participate in the link 90-day challenge
and
i hope some of you will join me in these
language workouts and if you can't be
there for that time slot live you will
be able to see the video at youtube so
[Music]
it's gonna i i'm quite excited i have
indicated in another video what i hope
to achieve in arabic and farsi we'll see
how close i get to that and similarly i
wish you the
every success in achieving your goals as
well oh and one more thing in case
you're wondering how you find these uh
language workouts please read the
explanation in the
description box here for full details
anyway see you tomorrow bye
[Music]
you